kaufman here
um
one of the people who
follows my blog whose name is stefan
has asked me to do a video about
language learning and age
now first of all let me say that
this morning i played old timers hockey
uh most the guys are
65 68
70
um some are in their 60s early 60s
um
i tell you when i'm out there playing
hockey i think i'm 10
15.
it's the same feeling
except that we after the game we're
allowed to go and have a beer so i must
have been over the legal drinking age uh
we're having just as much fun
uh the same kind of conversation we're
trying just as hard in the game fighting
for the puck trying to make passes set
people up
this kind of thing
um probably uh less inclined to uh to
get into shoving matches and and and
that kind of stuff a little bit less
aggressive
um
so uh when i'm out there i think i'm 15
or 20.
um
you know i hate it when i go somewhere
and people ask me if i want the seniors
discount
because i i
i thought it was maybe
you know a lot younger than that how do
you know that i'm 66.
wow
um
to me age is largely in your mind
if you want to learn a language i don't
think age has much to do with it i am i
mean from the research and so forth
it appears that very young children
are able to learn very quickly because
and my understanding of it is that the
brain
has not yet sort of
crystallized that the brain is kind of
this darwinian space where different
different things are competing for for
room
and so if you have a lot of exposure to
language a
that will tend to become dominant if you
have a lot of exposure to several
languages you may be more flexible
i think
children under the age of 10 or 12 are
less inhibited they're into
communicating they're not worrying about
how they sound this kind of thing so
they they tend to do better
adults can often learn more quickly than
children to the extent that adults have
a much larger vocabulary in their own
language and so therefore they have more
reference points
um
i'm sure that
you know seniors
of my age
that their memory and and some of their
you know
neural skills have declined just like
their body is not as strong
uh but i i don't have the impression
personally that it impacts on my ability
to learn languages
i don't think language learning is so
much a matter of memory as i've said
before i think it's although memory
certainly plays a part i think it's more
a matter of noticing
you know if i'm listening to check i
have to notice how it's pronounced i
have to notice
where you know the
emphasis
is in a word
i have to notice certain structures i
try to make them natural i try to
remember certain things but i can't
remember what i can't notice and so i i
think noticing is is the big thing
and i think noticing it depends on a
number of factors
uh it depends on our state of mind uh
are we interested do we think we can do
it are we alert are we you know keen
uh we're more likely to notice
if we are um i'm an experienced language
learner so i will notice certain things
if there are certain things in check
that are similar to russian i will
notice them
you know if if um
you know some tense things that uh i
mean i noticed for example the
similarity in all european languages in
terms of the structure of the verbs
these are things that i noticed because
i have learned so many languages
i think you notice if you expose
yourself to a lot of the language
through repetitive listening and and
eventually not so repetitive and and
reading and and so more and more things
become clear so that you're able to
notice these other things that you can't
notice at first
uh
i don't think any of these things relate
so much to age uh i mean i would be
quite willing to
to uh now i'm not a good example because
i'm an experienced language learner i've
learned a lot of languages but i don't
feel i feel that i'm a better language
learner today than i was when i was in
high school because i wasn't very
interested in high school and i had not
had the experience of converting myself
into a relatively fluent speaker of
another language
so i didn't have the confidence i didn't
i didn't know how to go about it um
i haven't noticed that it at my age that
i i forget things more quickly
um you know in my check i've been at it
for six months i'm i'm still pinching
myself that uh you know i had my i won't
look for it now but i had my
conversation with yarda and he sent me
his his comments at the bottom there
were 10 lines of comment there wasn't a
single word there that i didn't know
uh now obviously when i import
text about czech history or the story of
the life of
of bedrich smetana then there are more
words that i don't know but i can still
pick my way through those things and
i've been at it now
you know six months an hour and a half a
day kind of thing
i don't notice that i'm slowing down
um
so i mean if we look at the different
stages okay the infant for sure is going
to learn to pronounce like a native
because that's what they that's there is
nothing else interfering with that uh
they will
you know even as children younger
children under the age of 10 12 they'll
just communicate naturally
without any inhibitions without feeling
self-conscious and to that extent they
will more naturally learn the language
but once you pass the age of 12 15
i haven't noticed any difference
[Music]
i guess if i remember when i was at
language school
studying chinese which was the only time
i actually went to a language school
i mean the assumption and there you had
you know
people sent there by their employer or
by the government or which their
employer to learn a language and the
assumption always was that the older guy
would have more trouble and at that you
know in those days i was 22
so to me a 45 year old was an old guy
and they did have more trouble
uh
but to me today a 45 year old is a young
guy
and i can't see why they would have
trouble and i look at my
son mark who uh has become somewhat
belatedly interested in languages he
wasn't that interested when we i was
trying to force him to learn french as a
child
but he learns very well
he's you know i would have thought him
old when i was studying
chinese i think a part of it is the way
i think a lot of the people who are past
20 they think they're not going to be
able to do it
they
are inhibited
they're easily embarrassed
they don't focus on noticing the
language because they're too much
concerned about themselves and worrying
about themselves and can i do it and how
do i sound and
and um
yeah i think i think if you approach
language learning as some kind of a
memory task or you're going to have to
remember a bunch of rules and a bunch of
vocabulary you can quickly persuade
yourself that you can't do it
if you approach language learning it's
something that you're going to basically
immerse yourself in through a lot of
listening and reading or if you're lucky
enough to live in the country where the
language is spoken you can get exposure
and if you feel that you're just going
to be able to learn it and
if you take the initiative of regularly
consulting a grammar book and here again
you talk about noticing
when i start noticing certain structures
and i wonder why then i'm quite keen to
go to the grammar book and look it up
and see some of the rules and the
patterns and and there it has a chance
of sticking whereas if it's kind of
forced on me according to some
curriculum today we're going to study
the subjunctive and i say like i don't
even know what the subjunctive is i
haven't even noticed it yet then it's
not going to stick but if i start
noticing it and why does the verb change
there then i'm ripe
and ready
to to learn that so
to me the big thing is
believing in yourself
liking the task liking what you're doing
um
enjoying it like i mean i go out
and does it matter if as an older person
you learn less quickly than as a younger
person i'm not sure you do but even if
you do you know does it matter to us a
bunch of 60 year old 60 plus people out
there playing hockey
uh having just a tremendous time
uh does it matter that in fact
we are much slower than we think we are
slower than we used to be or maybe we
were never that fast in the first place
uh
i don't think it matters so the quick
answer is i
am not convinced that age is a big deal
beyond childhood i i and if it is it's a
a relatively minor issue and what is
much more important is your attitude
uh
are you focused are you paying attention
are you exposing yourself enough to
enough of the language are you enjoying
the language are you enjoying the
process and if the answer to all of that
is yes
then the question of your age really
doesn't matter